welcome to the 2016 Google Play Awards
please welcome purnima Kochi car head of
apps and games BD Google Play good
evening how's everyone doing welcome to
the first ever Google Play Awards since
we announced this program about a couple
weeks ago there has been incredible
excitement from the developer community
and the press from all around the world
this would not be possible without you
and your work so give yourself a big
round of applause
looking back at how much we have
accomplished together since the since we
launched Google Play it's pretty amazing
and the momentum isn't letting up your
apps and games now reach a billion users
every month through Play
and they are driving 65 billion
downloads in 2015 alone pretty amazing
isn't it each day my team and I have the
privilege of working with you to help
you build successful mobile businesses
and each day you use the platforms and
tools we provide to create apps and
games that amaze and inspire us tonight
we take the time to celebrate you and
the great work you have done over the
last year tonight we honor 10 examples
of outstanding achievement
so let's get the show started shall we
all right
stand out
Indy please welcome Bob Meese head of
games BD Google Play hi everyone this is
a lot of fun what a great crowd tonight
thank you all right so in these provide
fun deep and meaningful experiences
spanning games of all genres they prove
that developers of any size can succeed
on Android I judged the first Google
Play indie festival last month and it
reminded me how much I love games in the
games industry we're thrilled to support
this community and it's so important to
us we have the indie corner which we
recently launched which is a dedicated
collection of indie games that we
promote on the Play Store let's look at
the nominees stared out indie nominees
are alpha bear
Altos adventure
fast like a fox
wing co-axial a kitty collector
oonh
we'll stand out in D all right you ready
the winner of the first-ever Google Play
award is alpha bear
best use of Google Play game services
all right for the next award so Google
Play game services fuel increased
competition on Google Play that helped
create a great community of gamers with
features like multiplayer and
leaderboards they help keep gamers
engaged and keep them coming back for
more all the nominees in this category
integrated multiple Google Play game
features that enhance the overall user
experience let's take a look at the
nominees is juice of Google Play games
services nominees see battle - table
tennis touch
Tapp ventures
our madness to
zombie highway to best use of Google
Play game services right for the next
one plus call the nominees all right and
the winner is table tennis touch
that's
best use of material design
please welcome Larisa Fontaine head of a
speedy Google Play so having recently
finished a home improvement project I
used even more new apps than I usually
do which is kind of a lot it was
incredible with the adoption of material
design how quickly I was able to
navigate and find recommendations and
ideas in well-designed apps they were
enjoyable intuitive and help me find
exactly what I was looking for without
having the hunt and peck and if not just
home improvement apps over 1 million
apps have adopted material design
elements in just the last two years
since we announced them this year's
nominees represent first-class material
design implementations across many
categories and the nominees are excuse
of material design nominees are bring
fabulous
Robin Hood
you doest
rivo best use of material design and the
winner is Robin Hood
standout startup
I'm I'm still here similar to our focus
on Indies this year we're putting
startup developers front and center and
as we've talked about a couple times
over the last two days we've launched an
early access program for apps that are
still in beta to connect developers with
a community of early adopters to get
great feedback earlier development we
are consistently amazed with the
incredible funnel of fresh and unique
experiences coming from lean teams and
this group of nominees represent
incredible startups from across the
ecosystem and the nominees are standout
startup nominees our dubsmash
hopper
musically Robin Hood
first
standout startup and the winner is
hopper
best families app please welcome Ben
Galbreath head of developer relations
developer product last May we launched a
dedicated family section in the Play
Store we did this to help developers
surface their apps and games to parents
and to provide a unique discovery
experience based on age and popular
characters as the father of eight young
children all one wife fall one at a time
this section is enormous ly popular in
our household we love these apps let's
take a look at the nominees best
families app nominees our car Dwarfs
Adventure Time
Lego Jurassic world
my Very Hungry Caterpillar think rolls
too
khoka nature
the best families app and the winner is
think rolls too
most innovative the most innovative
category highlights the apps and games
that bring the WoW moments that
demonstrate something truly new and
unique now this could form this would
come in the form of new controls for a
game based on the latest sensors or it
could be deep personalization that gives
you a intimate emotional connection to
the experience in whatever form it comes
innovation can transform something
ordinary into something immersive all on
a mobile device that fits in the palm of
your hand and the nominees are most
innovative nominees are fabulous
that's like a fox
New York Times be on
smart news
this war of mine most innovative the
winner is New York Times VR
early adopter
please welcome Samir cemaat VP product
management Google Play
I'm I'm I'm only realizing now that many
of you did not get the memo on the
appropriate dress code for this
evening's attire and you're forgiven
however but I wanted to look my best in
honor of some of the greatest developers
in the world and one of my one of the
favorite parts of my job is watching
developers take a new design or a
nascent technology and create
experiences that are truly changing
people's lives the apps and the games
that they create offer a service piece
of functionality or an entirely new
experience that is truly inspiring and
amazing being an early adopter is really
hard it means challenging the status quo
it means pushing your team in different
directions
these are all things that we at Google
truly admire in this year's nominees
let's take a look
early adopter nominees are Glide
mechanic's escape
minecraft story mode
world around me
semper early-adopter
and the winner this year in the early
adopter category is world around me
go global given how popular Android
devices are around the world we often
get asked by developers how do I make an
successful entrance into a new market
and many people think that localizing an
app just means taking the app from one
language to another but it's so much
more than that for an app to feel truly
successful in a different country users
there need to believe that it was built
for them this is all about colors and
character choices and contextual
relevance as well as language it's
really hard to do and so this year we
wanted to honor a set of developers that
exemplify what great localization looks
like and the nominees are let's take our
dragon ball z dokkan battle
poletik spotty wait
memorize
musiXmatch Pokemon shuffle mobile go
global and the winner this year in the
go global category Pokemon shuffle
mobile
best app please welcome Jaime Rosenberg
VP Google Play hi everyone it's
incredibly humbling just looking out at
this room it's incredibly humbling as a
reminder to see how far our Android
developer community has come since we
first launched the platform back in 2008
we're now at the final two award
categories of the night best app and
best game the nominees in these
categories are true examples of the
amazing work being done by all of you
and our Android developers all over the
world
first the award for best app whether
you're looking for recipe ideas for a
home remodel or ways to stay informed or
entertain the nominees in this category
make your day more productive and more
fun they serve their users in different
ways but what they all have in common is
great design intuitive user experience
and broad appeal let's take a look at
the nominees for best app these are high
speed news
poli-sci
house
tune in radio
best app and the winner of the award for
best app is house
right
best game I have to try that one at home
later so this year's nominees for best
game give everyone a reason to be a
gamer from big screen characters to
small screen heroes from puzzles to
clans to battles these nominees connect
and delight users everywhere and they're
also a ton of fun they also tend to
showcase the very best of what an
Android device can do so let's take a
look at the nominees for best game best
game nominees are alpha bear
clash royale marvel future fight
Star Wars galaxy of Heroes best game and
the winner of the Google Play award for
best game is clash Royale
all right
please welcome back to the stage purnima
Kochi car all right one more huge round
of applause for all the nominees and the
winners please make some noise with so
many amazing apps and games it was an
extremely difficult task for the panel
to pick the nominees and the winners
thank you for constantly pushing the
boundaries to show us what's possible I
hope you had a good time tonight and I
hope you're energized to go out and use
the new tools and features that we
announced all through IO to create new
apps and games
my team and I are eagerly waiting to see
what you will create next it's
constantly we are constantly amazed and
it's what makes our jobs fun every day
but first it's time to go out and have
some fun please join us for after hours
happening all around the venue good
night and thank you